think that there
are guys that actually like bigger women
yeah yeah
okay so if if so why is it that when a
man gets money and he has more options
than any other man or an nba player
whatever like
basically like the top guys when they do
get money they go for models and women
that are not plus size when they get the
choice
at that stage they go over something
different like when you've made so much
money that's why you hear about all this
like crazy
like gay [ __ ] in hollywood like no not
yet gays let me put whatever
i'm just saying like people try to just
they just do different things like
when you make so much money like money's
not an option and like you've got hoes
coming to your door like you've got man
come like
money's not issues you should be like
all right let me let me try this let me
try that like
like there's no type at that point yeah
i'm saying like when you're hitting that
like upper epsilon like it's just
different world like
if you you'll be sat wherever on like a
tuesday yeah and you've got like
40 50 of
victoria's secret models or whatever
like they always do that's what i'm
saying are they are they chubby chasers
because like like sorry
do they like bigger women because like
they actually like bigger women or they
just don't get to choose
between like they don't get the choice
for the models i hear yourself yeah so
i'm sorry basically it's like so
obviously when you've got mad bread yeah
these man you pick all the
chubby things so you're saying some of
the i guess like
people that aren't on that level you may
see them with more
less attractive people and she's saying
is that more just because of
like that is what is available to you or
is that your choice as soon as you've
got more choice right that's what life
is about like if you have options like
if you're at a restaurant and you're
struggling to eat it's only struggling
because you have so many options so so
then could we argue that they don't
actually like overweight women they just
they just don't get the ch they just
settle because they don't get if they
are 100 proof on like again chubby
chubby what do you call them i like that
one
cases at all times and that's a fetish
or whatever it could be life as well
like if you're let's say you grow up in
in that from like young like yeah your
parents made crazy money or they've got
like big crazy stats or whatever
from young you're growing up with this
kind of like i guess mindset of honor
you're being around probably certain
type of crowd you're having so much
attention on yourself so maybe like your
ethics or morals are different whereas
maybe if
you was just
more like a regular regular like your
morals that you grow up with might be
different so then what you
one an epitomize in a female might be
different therefore the
that outer shell of a female may be less
important to you
because i've just never seen a guy get
money status and like things that women
like and pick the big girl i can't think
of one i don't know maybe they don't
pick him on on like in public but they
they're gonna bring it back
they're gonna bring him back
that doesn't count like give commitment
because that's a woman want commitment i
think a lot of dudes in like the me like
because i guess the people we're talking
about
a lot of celebrities or like people that
are well know i think a lot of them are
in the
media you'll see them maybe with the
model type because that's what's
portrayed in the media but i think
there's thousands behind closed doors
that are like millionaires and sports
and rare that
aren't in the media like
people that you probably don't really
know about like nba players are
maybe you don't hear about too much that
their wives are just you seeing a little
bit
maybe not super attractive yeah
other people you've seen little doug's
first wife right the white girl i am
sorry i didn't even say but like she is
the most ugliest person that's crazy and
that's his wife bro no it's not no like
that's what i'm saying no it's baby mom
first baby and it was like a picture
from like 2013 like was he famous then
not as much but
people bring it up to this day like
so so he kind of traded up when he got
the chance
that's what you're saying nah because i
don't think he should have done that in
the first place i'm not gonna lie
i haven't seen him i'm not the one that
did like bad things
well she he might i love doing this
he might have
seen him i swear pull up the picture
like no one's going to say that for sure
it's like you know what it was out here
you know when you meet someone like
africans are not like for a green card
that's the moment like that is what it
was but that's what i said like dating
the night what's the night what day is
dating what about africans
oh huh well what about africa
mic check